olga is her name and her boys are harry  they're from the donbass in ukraine's  far east they were the first people we  met at the station this morning  and we didn't need to ask their story  came tumbling out  by train car bus and on foot they  traveled across ukraine to safety but  it's done little for her state of mind  and no wonder  it was  [Music]  [Music]  and then with news that their next train  will leave soon they pack up and they  move on  past others whose stories are just the  same  along the concourse  down and up to platform 2.  greece is her goal and family there  there's a final farewell  and then they're on their way  mark stone sky news in poland